but I have to say Ben's on the screen  appearances began a quite nerdy age  now I think you were a teenager weren't  you dude anyone remember Ben whistles  fine work in a series not just one at  the series of Birdseye ads how old are  you in these about 17 18 when I see it  maybe I'll be able to be more accurate I  think I'm about 17 okay this is  obviously it'll make you want to get in  birds I chicken curry here you go  chicken curry interesting it's got herb  spices and 100% chicken breasts easy  tasty birds I  I remember that day very well because  they couldn't use real steam and it had  to look piping hot this chicken curry  and the real steam for some reason  wasn't reading and to my alarm  suddenly there was a broke next to me  with a long straw very long straw  puffing a cigarette through the chicken  [Laughter]  you're brilliant in it yeah it's usually  old ads just funny but that's a was  meant to be funny  [Music]  you